[Applause]
thank you everybody for sticking around
for the last session this is my first PI
data event I'm really happy to be here
it's been a great conference so far and
I will try to keep it that way all right
so let's make sure you're in the right
place let's start off as as real
engineers let's define an objective and
constraints so what we want to do on
this talk is build an online interactive
data application now in software there
are a million ways to do that so let's
apply our constraints and focus our
approach a little bit so this is a
Python conference so we want to do this
in Python we won't be using R or
anything else and we want this to be
zero cost and that means zero cost for
personal use and zero cost for
enterprise use so now we can start
making decisions about what kind of
technologies we would we would like to
use so because we want to build
something that's online and interactive
we need Java Script but we don't need to
decide on the Java Script library right
away the first decision we need to make
is actually what Python library we want
to use the reason is because all of
these Python libraries that you see here
are actually bindings around JavaScript
libraries so once we choose the Python
library we just get whatever JavaScript
library comes with that so for this talk
as indicated in the title we are going
to be using Python boquete I'll tell you
reasons why I chose why I like to use
Python boquete later in the talk but for
now let's just go with it
once we choose python boquete that means
we'll be using the bouquet javascript
library
what python bouquet gives us is just a
data application once we have that data
application we need a platform on which
to deploy it so we need to decide on
some kind of deployment later and
because one of our constraint one of our
constraints is zero cost for enterprise
use we're just going to use a linux
server we're not going to use platform
as a service or anything where you might
have to pay later on all right so this
is a dense talk at times you don't have
to remember all the details I have a
personal website our BTech blog com
there's a blog post where you can read
about exactly what I'm talking about
here so sit back and enjoy
so why Python bouquet for me and after I
saw that the Python bouquet development
team had reproduced the Gapminder
visualization Gapminder is a relatively
famous interactive data visualization if
you search for it you'll find a TED talk
I encourage everybody to watch that TED
talk essentially what it is it attempts
to communicate the statistics of how
different countries develop in time so I
don't think you can read the axes but
what we have are metrics that quantify
more or less the development of
countries children per woman and life
expectancy in years and every data point
the size of the circle is proportional
to the population of the country and the
color of the circle is encodes what
region of the world that's in now I'm
gonna play this for you this is just me
interacting with this with it in my
browser I just recorded a video of it so
there's China there's India there's
Taiwan once we get farther to the left
and sorry the year is just not showing
up here there's supposed to be a year
that says 1964 right here so I'm gonna
press play and I don't think you see
this but you should see the year
incrementing right here 1988 1990 1995
2000 sorry you don't see that but oh you
do oh there okay it's actually much
bigger right here but yeah you guys you
guys don't see that so what you can see
is how countries develop in time and
it's really it's really great to see
that I encourage you to to Google this
and watch the rest of that presentation
now if if you do go to the original
presentation you'll see that they use
some very specialized software to create
this something that was developed
clearly just for this purpose
but Python bouquet with you know the
normal Python bouquet pack
to reproduce this and I thought that was
really great and that convinced me that
I should be using Python but Python
bouquet for my own work okay so a more
formal explanation why Python bouquet it
was built for web browsers if you ever
if you ever decide to use Python bouquet
you'll notice that right away everything
just pops up right in the web browser
I've been using it for about two years
and I haven't been restricted at all
everything that I can imagine that I
want to visualize that's useful in a
scientific and engineering context I can
create that with Python bouquet it's got
a nice API I'll show you some code later
and and we'll kind of see what's what's
nice about the API okay at this point in
the talk I would like to tell you about
how I use interactive data applications
at my company but in order for that to
make sense you the audience kind of
needs to know what my company does so
we're gonna have a fun little diversion
I'm gonna tell you what I do and how
data science is involved and if I've
been successful then you the audience
should have a better idea of how
computer chips are manufactured okay so
I work for cyber Cymer builds lasers we
don't build the lasers that mounts on
the heads of sharks unfortunately I wish
we did this is the laser that we build
that's what it looks like it's about as
tall as I am the width is 2/3 the length
of the average shark so let's let's
compare the Cymer laser to my laser
pointer
this one my laser pointer is a very dumb
laser I push a button it either works or
it doesn't work it looks like green
light but you don't know exactly what
shade of green light you don't know what
intensity of green light you have no
control over the green light it's it's a
very very dumb laser the Siemer laser on
the other hand is is a really
intelligent laser a really smart laser
so the output instead of constant light
it's light pulses and you can get up to
6,000 pulses per second if that's what
you want and each pulse of light is
exactly what the user asks for so before
the pulse is fired the user has some
interface where they can ask
for specific wavelength a specific
energy and then the laser delivers
exactly that that pulse of light and
before the pulse of light exits the
system its measured so the user knows
the user knows what they asked for and
what they get unlike my laser pointer
the way that works is we have onboard
sensors everywhere in this system we
have onboard computers everywhere in the
system and we have onboard actuators
everywhere in this system it's actually
more computer than laser this this
system and really most importantly we
have a relatively large team of control
engineers that write very advanced
feedback control algorithms to make all
this work and we have a embedded
software team and kind of all the
engineering teams that you would expect
so for the most part this works all day
every day it delivers the light meeting
the specifications that our customers
care about and this is a remarkable
achievement for a laser system in
addition to the light output all of
these onboard sensors output data a lot
of data and that's good news for a data
scientist if you're interested in
purchasing a laser for your living room
or patio or wherever this is this is the
approximate cost 1.5 million Cymer was
sold in 2013 for that number right there
we were sold to a company called a SML
Cymer and a sumela are both in the
semiconductor lithography industry that
means manufacturing computer chips so
I'm going to show you a video of the a
SML machine this is the machine that the
Cymer laser attaches to this machine is
much bigger than the Siemer laser and
way more expensive so the blue flashing
light that you see in there that's the
light from the seiner laser it's going
through some optics and it's going
through this metal cheesegrater thing
that's called the mask that contains the
pattern that is printed on two silicon
wafers there is a silicon wafer it just
finished being printed it's exiting the
system it's going to be sliced and
packaged into computer chips that go
into phones and computers and watches
and all the other electronic device
here's another wafer it just entered the
system the first thing you need to do is
measure the surface of the wafer exactly
because when you are doing
photolithography dimensions of
nanometers are critical here's another
wafer it's just exiting the system the
wafer whose surface was just measured is
now under this projection lens that's a
very expensive component as well so
we'll zoom out and we'll see the mask
again and so on and so forth all right
data science is pretty challenging in
this environment
number one we just have a lot of data to
work with
so the Cymer laser outputs thousands of
time-series signals there are thousands
of events that can happen on a laser
where each event has its own custom set
of data there's lots of unstructured
service data manufacturing data and we
just have thousands of systems all over
the world all models are useful all
models are wrong but some are useful so
the price of being wrong in this
industry is very high semiconductor
lithography is one of those industries
where downtime is measured in some crazy
number like millions of dollars per hour
so we can't build models that are wrong
and I hope you took away from that video
that this process is very orchestrated
and complex so there's no time for
algorithms in the cloud or anything like
that everything has to be fast and
embedded and automated all right let's
now that you know a little bit about the
industry I'm going to play for you a
Python bouquet application running on a
Linux server that I created to be used
within this company so I mentioned that
the laser outputs thousands of
time-series signals so depending on the
problem that you have you're not going
to want to look at thousands of
time-series signals you just want to
look at the handful that are relevant to
your problem so I built this application
what you do is you choose from the
drop-down menus what what it is that you
want to look at of course we have to
train the people using this to
understand if you have problem a you
look at signals a B and C and so on and
so forth so and then you can zoom you
can pan you can do all the kind of inter
of tricks you would expect to do here
we're looking at three signals that
might be relevant to some problem in
case it's not we can use these buttons
to remove figures and add figures and
just kind of get the right data in front
of our faces that that helps us solve
some specific problem all right so
enough about lasers professor Albert
Alberto Cairo talked to us on Wednesday
at 1:15 p.m. about charts and he
mentioned that a picture is not worth a
thousand words or Chartres is not worth
a thousand words it's only worth the
amount of words that are supported by
information in the chart so here's a
chart this is from the Washington Post
basically what it's saying is that 2018
was a volatile year for stocks but if
you took out all you've all of your
money in in October it was a good year
for you otherwise it was a bad year so
there's nothing wrong with that I think
professor Cairo would think this is a
good chart because it it just says the
says the words that support that is
supported by information in the charts
and nothing more but could we use Python
boquete to make this a little bit more
informative right the answer is yes we
can this is another interactive data
visualization from my tech blog and what
we're doing here is we have a list of
stocks on the left and we're kind of
scanning our cursor along those and then
right underneath you see the time series
history of each of those stocks more
importantly more importantly though we
have this colorful chart at the top and
this chart what what I'm doing in that
chart is is normalizing the the price of
every stock to a value of 1 on January
1st and then we can kind of see
throughout the year for a large
collection of stocks what is the stock
market doing for the for these stocks so
if we go back to the Washington Post
visualization what they're doing is
aggregating by a collection of stocks
everything and we're losing all that
information about what individual stocks
are doing but if we have a tool like
interactive data visualization we
can get that information back and
roughly the same amount of space so the
answer is yes
Python bouquet on Linux server which was
how this was developed increases the the
information density by in this case
enabling multi-dimensional data
exploration data exploration without
excessive aggregation alright so I think
I've covered a lot let's let's have a
little recap I hope everybody knows why
we're here I hope you know a little bit
about how computer chips are
manufactured I hope I've given you
enough examples of Python bouquet
running on Linux server to convince you
that it's something that you might want
to do for your own work okay so now
let's finally dig in and and talk about
how to actually build something like
this
so no more kind of fancy interactive
data applications from here on out we're
going to work with this very simple
interactive data application just just
to use it as something baseline that we
can build and we can understand and then
you can extend it after that so there's
really three steps to building something
like this step one we need to build
build the Python bouquet application and
test it locally so let's just make let's
just make sure it works on our own
computer after that we need to put it we
need to put it on the internet so we
need some platform for that so step two
is go out and get a Linux cloud server
and then there's three there's two
things you can do for step three if
there's just a handful of people in the
world that want to see it if you're not
really worried about server security or
robustness you can actually deploy it
online very quickly so I'm going to
cover that approach but if you have a
lot of people that want to look at it
and you're a little more worried about
security and robustness there's a
there's another approach we can take and
we're going to cover that as well all
right so let's look at the Python
bouquet API a little bit and what I
would like for you to focus on is what
is graphics code what is layout code
boilerplate code and deployment code one
of the nice things about bouquet is
there's actually not a whole lot of
boilerplate code
especially if you compare it to let's
say PI QT for example there's there's a
ton of boilerplate if you're making a PI
QT application so let's look at layout
code layout code you see that in line 20
so I so here we are saying that the
layout we want is a column layout where
the button is on top of the figure so
that's what that's what's actually
creating creating the layout notice that
before line 20 we've said nothing about
layout we've said that let there exist a
figure object that's what we say in line
8 but we don't say we're in the
application should the figure object
live line 17 we say let there exist a
button object but nothing about where
the button object should live and then
finally once we get to line 20 we said
let's make a column layout so this is
nice because if we want to change
something about the figure the code to
make the figure is isolated from
everything else if you want to change
something about the layout it's it's
isolated so when you're building larger
applications this becomes really
important that that the major components
of the application are compartmentalized
so you can change things independently
the deployment code is running in the
terminal so I think I left this detail
out this is the Python module that
represents the bouquet application what
we do is we open a terminal we go to the
directory where that Python module lives
and we say bouquet serve button py - -
show and then we get the same
visualization that we had before except
it's running in localhost at port 5006
so let's move on alright so we have the
we have the bouquet application running
locally so we want to get it on the
Internet as quickly as possible
forget about security and robustness we
just want it online so we can start
sharing it with some people so what's
what's the fastest way to do that the
first thing that we need is a cloud
server now in principle we could use our
own computer and expose that to the
internet but it's 2019 so let's use an
infrastructure as a service provider
a really nice provider as digitalocean
for five bucks a month we can get a
cloud server the important thing that
you need to remember about the cloud
server is its it's defined by an IP
address and after we get the cloud
server we need to upload our python
module to that cloud server the next
thing we do and I'm going to assume that
the audience knows how to do this
install Python install bouquet I think
that's a good assumption
after talking with everybody here all
right and then after we have Python and
boquete installed we log in to our cloud
server and we run bouquets serve button
dot py and instead of - - show we say -
- allow web socket origin and this tells
the bouquet server that people going to
this IP address and this port should be
allowed to see this application all
right and that does it that's it that's
all you need to do to deploy a bouquet
application online at this at that point
you could send to your buddies the IP
address and the port number and they
could they could look at at what you've
built this is great this works but it's
not very secure and it's not very robust
but like I said if you just have a
handful of people that you're working
with this this might be okay so this is
what the fast approach gives you it's
bad because you have an unsecured cloud
server Alberto Cairo would not approve
because all we've given the user is the
data application we've provided no words
to describe the meaning of it so we
really need to embed it in some webpage
and write about it right provide provide
the words that are supported by the
information in the visible and the
visualization the bouquet server was not
meant for production that's a problem so
what we're going to do is I'm going to
tell you about a robust approach to
doing the same thing where we fix all of
those fix all of those problems this is
what we're going to end up with at the
end of the day alright so let me outline
that robust approach what we want to do
is again start with a cloud server well
use digitalocean and I'm not going to
tell you how to secure a cloud server I
will just tell you to search for
digitalocean server setup they published
a tutorial it's very nice supported
updated they have a drop-down menu
depending on what version of Linux you
have selected and there's lots of
comments and questions so they they can
do a much better job telling you how to
do this than I can the next step is
create a template flask application
again just search digitalocean
flask Engine X you'll find the support
the online tutorial it's supported I
asked a question there it was answered
almost immediately they can do a much
better job than I can do what I'm going
to tell you how to do and what is
outlined again in the tech blog are the
steps they're after
so how do we extend the flask
application with an embedded bouquet
application and there's really three
steps we're going to cover each of those
this is kind of where we get into server
configuration so just stay with me okay
the first thing we need to do is
automate the bouquet server so if the
linux server reboots for whatever reason
everything just starts up automatically
and the bouquet server kind of runs in
the background this is this is the
proper way to do it so we are going to
use the system D Linux service utility
the instructions for doing that are
actually up in the digital ocean
tutorials that I just referenced so if
you complete those you'll understand
this configuration file much better
notice that we have a lot of the same
elements that we have when we use the
very fast approach the fast approach
said bouquet serve button dot py this
option so we have all those same things
in this file and there's bouquets serve
there's button dot py here's our IP
address I'm using a different port
because we're using on just a different
approach so now I'm using port 5100 I'm
putting the application at the relative
path slash bouquet and the application
name is button dot py keep keep in mind
those three things because they have to
remain consistent after this the next
thing that we do is embed the bouquet
application in the flask application
this is a very basic flask application
file there's a lot of bad coding
practices going on here but don't don't
hold that against me the bouquet API
gives you a function bouquet dot embed
server document which does exactly what
we want to do here it allows you to
embed a bouquet server document inside
of a flask application the output of
that function is an HTML tag object the
input is just the location of the
application bouquet in our case slash
bouquet slash button which is consistent
with our last bit of server
configuration the way you send this tag
to your HTML file is like you see here
you don't have to remember that just go
to our BTech blog comm the final piece
to this puzzle is we need to put the
bouquet server behind a reverse proxy so
that we are not using the bouquet server
in production if you follow the
digitalocean tutorials they talk a lot
about engine X and how it's how it's
used for this for this approach after
going through those tutorials you'll
recognize this configure this
configuration file we have to extend
that by adding a new location block in
that new location block has to be
consistent with everything that we've
defined up to this point it is here's
your port 5100 here's your bouquet
server location slash bouquet if you
like more information or if you want to
use something else like Apache for your
reverse proxy search running a bouquet
server and the bouquet team has created
some documentation about that so that's
it you do that and you have a robust
deployment on a linux server of a
bouquet application embedded in flask so
I know this is very simple but you can
imagine how we could build something
more complicated here more useful and
then we would describe it in flask just
like we would build any other web page
so that's it
quiz for you guys let's see if if if you
can get this if I navigate it to the IP
address
the cloud server / bouquet what would it
what would it show me is that what
you're pointing to yeah exactly
yeah it just it just gives you the
bouquet application at that point
because that's where we asked the
bouquet application to live very good
all right thank you and I'll take any
questions any questions yes
hey earlier we had a talk by the plot
lead team team scuse me
I was just wondering for you to use that
at all no I found okay first I liked it
and I stayed with it
yeah I've seen other people use plotly
and I heard about - today so those those
also look useful
there's the Python bouquet server
handled all of the sub selection if you
had a billion point time series record
does it it telogen tlie stride through
the data to plot it by by default no it
doesn't but the the bouquet team
recognized that and they built an
extension which I which I have not used
it's called data shader you can you can
search like você data shader data shader
and there's PI data talks about that
given by an actual member of the bouquet
team which which I'm not and it looks
very impressive yes for the actual
sensor data did you end up streaming
that data in and if so what what
technologies did you use for that know
that the way that system works is the
laser is running in the field it's
collecting data and then every so often
it sends it back to to San Diego it goes
into a database and then the application
reads from that database bouquet does
support streaming data this is so again
I'm not I'm not a representative of
bouquet
you-you-you could probably find a
presentation about bouquet streaming
it's I know it's advertised on the on
the on the main page of bouquet bouquet
de pie de de org that it supports large
and streaming data sets so I just that
it does but it's I haven't used it
I want to thank you for exposing this
I've never seen this it's gonna solve a
problem for me so thank you thank you I
did a quick search on the web this does
work in Jupiter notebooks have you had
an experience of that yay or nay
no I I haven't I've seen it done in
Jupiter notebooks that the people that
are looking at the applications I build
don't want to have anything to do with
Python or Jupiter they just want to go
to a web page and see what they need to
see it's actually going to be easy for
easier for you to build something that
works in Jupiter because it's more
tightly integrated you-you-you can avoid
a lot of the server configuration that I
talked about your questions
[Applause]